will let the investigations begin the
new Republican house is ready to bring
accountability to Washington and
President Biden himself one of their
first big targets will be collusion
between Tech Giants and the White House
House Republicans are expected to launch
a new panel the weaponization of the
federal government that will seek emails
memos and other Communications from
Biden officials and the incoming House
of the chair chair of the house
oversight committee says they will
finally get to the bottom of President
Biden's involvement in his family's
overseas business schemes
let me be clear we're not investigating
Hunter Biden we're investigating Joe
Biden and I think any American who's
kept up with the political process over
the past two administrations would agree
we need to know uh what is allowable and
what isn't allowable with respect to uh
foreign adversarial uh intervention
among family members of presidents of
the United States
but of course the media isn't taking the
new Republican majority very well
the keys have been handed over to
extremists the Republicans don't want to
govern they're locusts and they feed on
dysfunction and suffering what is going
to be a problem is if the American
people will be held captive over the
next two years to the extreme Mega
Republican agenda
so Greg yes
thoughts my thoughts are this maybe I
just started paying attention but I feel
like this country has become like one
big giant courtroom and all the
politicians or the political parties are
a type of lawyer they're trial lawyers
who have no desire to compromise until
the very end right so no because no
trial lawyer will say I see your point
whoever you're doing is so we've adopted
this model Nationwide so now you have
this ping pong thing if when they're in
power they do investigations and then
when we're in power we do investigations
which I am all for because payback's
[ __ ] I'm sorry
um Majorca he needs to be filleted over
whip gate the 52 Intel experts they all
have to be grilled over this we know
that they did there was some something
smelly going on there of course the FBI
I want to know how much they were
involved in pushing initiating illegal
acts that got people into trouble and of
course the big guy that's what this
whole thing about it's not about hunters
cocaine and hookers although that's
going to be fun to listen to right it's
like a Warren Zevon song I would but but
it's about it's about collude meeting
with China or selling your influence to
China uh at the harm of America but um
most of these investigations by the
Democrats early on were projections of
their own malfeasance right you know the
you know the escalations and violence uh
Rush inclusion all these things so pay
it really isn't payback at all it's
redirecting the truth redirecting the
justice and perhaps punishment in the
right direction towards Jessica and her
ilk her disgusting ilk
um
Dana the White House counsel has already
said they need to start over that
they're not going to comply with their
document requests and to bring it on
essentially they're just going to say
well look tactically from the White
House's perspective I can understand it
and I think that if it had been a
republican White House they would have
done the same thing I mean that's just
that's smart but they won't be able to
run forever and these hearings will
happen I think that one of the most
important hearings is one that James
Comer said is going to be first and that
is an investigation into what happened
to all the covid funds I mean that talk
why isn't that a bipartisan concern we
all were very generous with taxpayer
dollars to go to a lot of places there's
so much fraud they don't have enough
lawyers to even deal with that even the
begin to deal with it how about all the
money that went to schools but was it
used for the schools like that's useful
all the way to other things like over
the weekend we found out that the the
January 6 committee I think accidentally
but still how does it happen that you
release the social security numbers of
all all sorts of people who maybe went
to a holiday party at the White House
and now there's also a security number
is compromised and they have to go
through all the Hoops to deal with that
so there's big things like the coveted
funds and the Biden Hunter stuff we'll
we'll see about that but also I do think
that there are things like as you said
payback is a
b word a b word
jesse have you checked to see if the
Biden White House released your social
security number from when you went to a
party at the Trump White House my
father's so afraid of losing a social
security number you won't even like text
me the number he thinks it's going to
get stolen the Republicans Dana
respectfully when they were asked by
everybody about the Russia collusion
thing they gave them everything
tens of thousands of emails and text
messages from everyone on the Trump
campaign had to hire lawyers go through
depositions and give people their cell
phones and their computers for two years
now the Biden White House is going to
say no sorry we're not giving you
anything no that's not going to fly and
if someone tells you they've never been
to New York City and then you find
receipts of them from New York City
restaurants pictures of them with the
Empire State Building in the background
voicemails for them saying I had a
really great time hunter in NYC let's do
it again sometime you're wondering what
they're hiding about their trip from New
York City that's Joe Biden he has said
he's never talked to his son about his
business he's never his son's never made
any money in China it's a bold-faced lie
so the the the problem is the median if
they're gonna cover it or cover it up
they have news divisions in these in
these networks and then they have these
investigative units CBS has Catherine
Herridge they have good ones at the NBC
investigative you these are these are
good guys
they can't come out and say yeah we have
Smoking Gun evidence they took six
million dollars from the Communist
Chinese and we have photos of Joe Biden
with Chinese guys oh
and then and then the rest of the CBS
News division comes out and it's like oh
yeah the Republican partisan attack
machine like you can't reconcile that so
you can't set a present where you know
the FBI and the CIA can interfere in an
election and cover up presidential
corruption to swing an election and just
say okay you know it's the partisan
which you cannot do that so Jessica
Democrats so far seem like they're
making the argument that doing oversight
whether it's Biden or other issues is
simply an excuse for Republicans quote
not to govern
well if would you agree with that no I I
don't know along that I think that there
are some investigations like to your
point in about the covet funds I don't
know anyone who isn't interested in all
of the PPP fraud right all of the Mega
rich people who got richer who were
stealing from the rest of us certainly
the teaching we're going to talk about
what's going on with the teachers unions
in a couple segments from now
we should claw money back if it's not
being spent appropriately I think you
could get bipartisan support for
understanding the origins of covet
I think that we are at that point now
where there are bipartisan majorities
who want to know just what happened here
just tell us what happened we would like
a clear line to the truth about this but
to your point about not governing there
was polling that came out over the
weekend now that we have a majority
leader house Speaker McCarthy what do
you want to be the Republican priorities
number one fighting inflation that was
the same thing that they said about the
Democrats 78 percent loud and clear
number two uh protecting Medicare and
Social Security and there have been a
number of Republicans who've already
been on TV including Congressman Mike
Waltz who were talking about earlier who
said we're going to have to look at
entitlements that's going to be an issue
for voters you know what only got 31
support investigating Joe Biden so you
can go ahead and do it I'm not afraid of
it if you find out that he's the most
corrupt president in American history
impeach him get him out of there but if
you want to win in 2024 you better not
look like all you're doing is chasing
pictures of Joe and Hunter and a Chinese
guy around the city that's it's not
going to fly saying this after five
years of that being done to Trump think
about it that's but that's not true
because it's Trump right no it's not
true because it's not true
we've got to get his tax returns okay I
I don't understand how that isn't
directly relevant to how the man has
governed that he got richer while he was
in office that he lied about things like
not taking a salary that his kids who
are getting trademarks all over the
world from countries where the where the
officials are coming to stay at Trump
International hotels right now you're
being a trial attorney let's hand over
them I wish I should have gone to law
school I wanna Brian kill Mead I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now